[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ich möchte, dass du mich ankündigst
als "The one and only".
>> SALLY: Echt jetzt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Mr. Universe?
>> MURAT: Mr. Universe mindestens.
Und andere Planeten auch.
>> SALLY: Huh!
Okay.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe mir gedacht, weil ja le-
– nächste Woche, nicht letzte Woche –
weil ja nächste Woche Valentinstag ist,
machen wir doch was schönes Besonderes.
Natürlich mache ich dieses Video nicht alleine,
sondern ich brauche einen fachkompetenten Partner
an meiner Seite:
The one and only
[Applaus]
Mister Universe 2008.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Applaus]
>> SALLY: Murat.
>> MURAT: Ich freue mich auch wahnsinnig auf die Sally.
Ich wäre jetzt lieber auf der Baustelle,
aber ich muss mit euch Valentinstagsdinge machen.
>> SALLY: Was heißt hier "muss"?
>> MURAT: Nee, ich mache es halt.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung? Das ist Ehetherapie, ja?
Ich habe mir gedacht...
>> MURAT: Darf ich noch ganz kurz was sagen?
>> SALLY: Ja, sag was.
>> MURAT: Nur ganz kurz. Ich möchte mich
jetzt gerade in diesem Moment
auch bei Frau Merkel bedanken,
weil wir Männer dieses Jahr
Valentinstag mit unserer eigenen Frau verbringen müssen.
>> SALLY: Ja, heute...
>> MURAT: Der war gut!
>> SALLY: Diesmal glaubt keiner, dass du,
>> MURAT: Der war richtig gut. Kommt jetzt.
>> SALLY: dass Männer am Valentinstag
einen Außergeschäftstermin haben außer Haus irgendwo:
>> SALLY: "Schatz, ich kann leider nicht kommen."
>> MURAT: Ja, so ist es. Danke schön.
>> MURAT: Ja, Valentinstag,
ein Riesenthema.
Die Leute, die mich schon seit sieben Jahren kennen,
wissen, dass ich da voll ausflippe, wenn Valentinstag kommt.
Da drehe ich total durch.
>> SALLY: Ach komm! Valentinstag 2007
hast du mir auch was Schönes geschenkt.
>> MURAT: Valentinstag,
>> SALLY: Das war das einzige Geschenk.
>> MURAT: Geburtstag, Muttertag,
– was gibt es noch alles? –
Hochzeitstag,
>> SALLY: Weltfrauentag,
>> MURAT: Weltfrauentag,
der Tag, an dem ich meine Frau kennengelernt habe,
an dem sie mir die ganzen Immobilien überschrieben hat,
alles Tage, wo ich jeden Tag feiern kann.
Es ist echt der Wahnsinn. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wir haben uns gedacht,
weil wir ja eigentlich schon so auf Instagram
das Vorzeige-Romantik-Ehepaar sind
>> MURAT: Ja. Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: – immer so: "Schatzi, Schatzi, ich liebe dich."
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und dann macht man so.
>> SALLY: Und dann machen wir so Liebespostings.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann zeigen wir so schöne Bilder,
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, wir sind das einzige Paar...
>> SALLY: tun Händchen halten.
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, wir sind das einzige Paar,
das auf Instagram keine
– doch, wir haben ein einziges in den sieben Jahren gemacht,
wo es ein bisschen verliebter aussieht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, ganz ehrlich, also ich meine, es läuft.
>> SALLY: Klopf auf Holz.
Es läuft ja zwischen uns.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Man muss es nur nicht immer
der ganzen Welt zeigen.
>> MURAT: Und nicht übertreiben.
>> SALLY: Und komm. Wie oft kam es schon vor?
Wir haben auch Freunde und Bekannte,
wo sie dann noch so einen Tag vorher so:
"O mein Schatz, ohne dich..."
Und am nächsten Tag Scheidung.
Muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, ja, kommt oft vor.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
>> MURAT: Und außerdem muss ich ehrlich sagen,
meine Mutter schaut zu
und ich will sie nicht irgendwie verstören.
>> SALLY: Ja, jetzt keinen Gefühlsüberschuss.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Also wollen wir jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Okay.
Jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht,
wir machen Pralinen
als Zeichen
>> MURAT: der Liebe.
>> SALLY: So Liebespralinen.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir machen so Liebespralinen und zwar
– das hat jetzt nichts mit Amorelie oder wie das heißt,
>> MURAT: Eis oder so was zu tun.
>> SALLY: Eis.de.
>> MURAT: Die sind aber aphrodisierend.
Also das heißt...
>> SALLY: Sollen wir noch aphrodisierende Zutaten reinmachen?
>> MURAT: Ja, wir machen aphrodisierende...
>> SALLY: Ah nee, bei dir bitte nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Schon. Sonst...
>> MURAT: Weil wir brauchen Kinder.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Um eure Partnerschaft
nicht auf eine Probe zu stellen,
sondern um eure Partnerschaft noch
emotionaler und tiefgründiger zu machen,
macht doch einfach diesen Pralinenkurs zusammen.
>> MURAT: Oder holt euch ein Netflix-Abo.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und ich denke,
wenn ihr die Pralinen zusammen schafft,
dann schafft ihr alles im Leben.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir fangen jetzt an.
Wir haben...
Wir haben ja Pralinenhohlkörper.
>> MURAT: Genau. Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Und...
>> MURAT: Hast du mich damit gemeint?
So.
Sie meinte die Schokolade.
Wenn Güni jetzt gerade zuschaut,
>> MURAT: sie meinte die Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Ich meinte die Schokolade.
>> MURAT: Das ist ein Hohlkörper.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir machen jetzt eine leckere Füllung.
Normalerweise machen wir Pralinen immer
mit so einer Toffee-Füllung
oder mit einer Trüffelfüllung,
also mit Schokolade und Sahne.
Ich habe mir jetzt aber gedacht,
wir machen mal was Leichteres
und vor allem was Gelingsicheres,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: damit es da keinen Ehestreit gibt.
>> MURAT: Ja, dass es auch wirklich jeder hinkriegt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und darf ich noch mal was sagen?
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Ich weiß, ich will jetzt nicht unterbrechen, aber
ihr könnt
– dieses Jahr könnt ihr...
Alles hat ja zu.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also auch die
– Blumereien wollte ich gerade sagen.
Ding...
>> SALLY: Floristen.
>> MURAT: Floristen und
Bäck- – nicht Bäcker,
sondern die Gärtner.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Ihr könnt trotzdem Blumen bestellen und sie abholen.
Also der Valentinstag ist für die ganzen Floristen
eigentlich fast der wichtigste Tag nach dem Muttertag.
Das heißt, bestellt was bei euch vor Ort in der Gärtnerei
und holt euch die Pflanzen ab.
>> SALLY: Eine Frage hätte ich noch.
>> MURAT: Ich habe es die letzten Jahre
immer am Friedhof gemacht.
>> SALLY: Eine Frage hätte ich da.
>> MURAT: Das mache ich dieses Jahr nicht mehr,
weil ich gern die...
>> SALLY: Wenn du die Floristen so gerne unterstützt,
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> SALLY: warum kriege ich nie Blumen?
>> MURAT: Ich habe eine Allergie.
>> SALLY: Okay, jetzt komm. Wir fangen jetzt an.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jedenfalls habe ich hier
schon mal Zutaten gerichtet.
Und du kannst auch noch sagen, was du gerne dazu hättest.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> SALLY: 100 Gramm Himbeeren,
– das waren tiefgefrorene,
denn es ist ja gerade keine Saison –
200 Gramm Quark,
– wir haben jetzt hier einen Magerquark –
50 Gramm Puderzucker,
150 Gramm Frischkäse
und 20 Gramm Kokosraspeln.
Okay? Oder wünschst du dir noch was?
Eine Zutat?
>> MURAT: Ja, 400 Gramm Rumpsteak mit Bratkartoffeln.
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Magst du vielleicht Tonka oder Vanille dazu?
>> MURAT: Ich würde eher Tonka nehmen.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gut, dann nehmen wir noch Tonka Wonka.
Meinst du, das ist aphrodisierend?
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, das ist aphrodisierend.
Man darf es aber nicht übertreiben,
muss ich ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Weil
es könnte in die Hose gehen.
Ja. Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay. Also das Erste, was wir jetzt machen:
die Himbeeren
auftauen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Weil ich so heiß bin. So.
Okay, ich halte das Ding jetzt einfach
und dann schmilzt das.
>> SALLY: Es kocht gleich. Uh!
>> MURAT: Wie soll ich das jetzt auftauen?
>> SALLY: In der Mikrowelle.
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Oder im...
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Oder im Topf.
Warum machen wir das nicht öfter?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich bin zwar ein heißer Typ,
aber das mache ich eher im Backofen.
So.
Hier zack.
Der ist eigentlich ganz einfach zu bieten.
Der ist idiotensicher.
Der wurde am Güni ausgetestet.
Und alles, was beim Güni ausgetestet wird, kann jeder.
So.
Menü, Mikrowelle,
600 Watt.
Geht doch.
>> SALLY: Fällt dir was an mir auf?
>> MURAT: Du warst beim Friseur.
Nee.
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: Was dann?
>> SALLY: Ich habe meinen Lippenstift vergessen
und jetzt habe ich ihn.
>> MURAT: Ach so. Nee, habe ich
– ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Gut.
Jetzt hier deine heißen Himbeeren.
>> MURAT: Ja, meine...
>> SALLY: Die kommen jetzt da rein.
Ihr könnt jetzt nämlich alle Zutaten
einfach in einem Mixer pürieren
oder mit einem Pürierstab.
>> MURAT: Also das ist ganz, ganz easy gemacht.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Nein!
>> MURAT: So.
Ja.
Jetzt müsste man es eigentlich so machen wie bei
– wie heißt der Film noch mal?
Dirty Dancing.
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Machen wir nicht.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm, alle Zutaten
>> MURAT: rein.
>> SALLY: Kannst du kurz Hände waschen?
Mich triggert das jetzt voll.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe so eine Phobie
gegen Abschlecken in der Küche.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
Und ja...
Ja. Und auf jeden Fall war es ja so:
Mir haben ja die Zuschauer Fragen gestellt, die ich dann...
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Hallo?
Wir machen hier gerade noch.
>> MURAT: Ach so. Okay.
>> SALLY: Wir müssen erst kurz pürieren und einfüllen
und dann machen wir die Fragen.
>> MURAT: Ich war so schnell wie so oft im Leben.
So.
>> SALLY: Jetzt das hier pürieren.
[Musik]
So.
>> MURAT: Das riecht voll nach Friedhof.
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Nein, wirklich, ohne Witz.
Irgendwie...
Das ist irgendwie so
>> SALLY: Findest du?
>> MURAT: komisch. Ja.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir es ein bisschen wegstellen?
Aber die sind so schön.
>> MURAT: Auf jeden Fall war es so:
Wir haben unsere Zuschauer gefragt
– was haben wir sie eigentlich gefragt?
>> SALLY: Wir haben eine Story gemacht und haben gesagt,
wir machen heute dieses Video
und stellt doch mir Fragen
>> MURAT: Über mich.
>> SALLY: über Murat
und stellt dem Murat Fragen über mich.
Und dann muss ich gucken,
ob ich die Fragen über ihn beantworten kann
und er über mich.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und ich habe
sieben Millionen Fragen gekriegt.
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> MURAT: Und ich suche mal
aus den sieben Millionen ein paar raus.
>> SALLY: Warte, Schatzi.
>> MURAT: Ja?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Er hält sich halt nie an Absprachen.
Ich habe gesagt, wir füllen erst ein
und dann machen wir die Fragen, während das kühlt.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay. Also wir füllen erst ein.
>> SALLY: Jetzt könnt ihr eine Dosierflasche nehmen
oder ihr nehmt einen Spritzbeutel
oder ein
– ja, eine Gefriertüte geht auch.
>> MURAT: Oder einen kleinen Trichter.
>> SALLY: Mh, so einen Minitrichter? Mhm.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt fülle ich das hier rein.
Wir machen natürlich zwei Flaschen.
Denn wir werden beide gießen.
[Musik]
So. Aus weiser Voraussicht
habe ich es jetzt mal so gemacht,
dass ich eine Flasche etwas voller gemacht habe.
Die nehme ich.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Mmh! Das schmeckt aber richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Mir wäre es jetzt eigentlich ganz recht...
Haben wir jetzt das Tonka Wonka vergessen?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ach!
Aber ist doch egal.
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was wir machen? Wir tun später...
Dann nehmen wir jetzt halt...
>> MURAT: Nee, mach doch Ding.
Hast du Knoblauch gegessen?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich nicht?
>> SALLY: Sag mal!
>> MURAT: Hey, die Dinger machen mich voll verrückt.
Weißt du das?
Die Pflanzen.
>> SALLY: Okay, mach.
Mach nicht so viel! O Gott!
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: O Gott!
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt müssen wir es einfach zumachen wieder.
Und dann kann man doch shaken.
Shake that shimmy, shimmy!
Shake that shimmy!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: So. Einfach mal schütteln.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es dir geht,
aber ich bräuchte die erhöhte Arbeitsplatte, wenn es geht.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir die reinschieben?
>> MURAT: Nee. Warum?
Was soll ich reinschieben jetzt?
Die Arbeits-
>> SALLY: Mein Gott!
>> MURAT: Lass doch.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Okay. Wir nehmen einfach das.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Wir haben jetzt hier
Zartbitterschokolade, Vollmilch und weiß.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Zu was tendierst du?
>> MURAT: Alles außer weiß.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich würde sogar sagen Zartbitter.
>> MURAT: Obwohl, weiß ist auch gut. Ja.
>> SALLY: Weißt du warum?
>> MURAT: Weil Zartbitter ist
– weil es bitter ist, ist es nachher nicht so süß.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und Schokolade ist aphrodisierend.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Zartbitterschokolade ist aphrodisierend?
>> SALLY: Hm, also Schokolade mit viel Kakaogehalt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hm. Also jetzt nicht, dass du es nötig hättest, aber
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: ich wollte es nur sagen.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: So.
Und jetzt einfüllen.
Natürlich in Partnerarbeit.
>> MURAT: Können wir so eine Musik spielen?
Guck mal. Es gibt eigentlich...
Es gibt zwei
– oder nee. Es gibt drei Hammersequenzen in Filmvideos,
also in Filmen.
Und zwar ist das einmal bei Titanic,
wenn der an der Reling steht.
Okay?
>> SALLY: O ja!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Dann gibt es noch die zweite Filmsequenz.
Das ist bei Ghost mit Patrick Swayze.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Spielen wir jetzt Ghost?
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Aber nicht, dass es jetzt schmuddelig wird.
>> MURAT: Und dann gibt es noch
die dritte coole Filmsequenz
und zwar das ist bei
>> MURAT: Harry und Sally!
>> SALLY: Nein, Dirty Dancing.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: Wenn die dann so losgeht
und er sie dann...
>> SALLY: Nein!
Ich will es nicht! Warte!
>> MURAT: Und er so.
Das sind die. Wirklich! Das sind die drei.
>> SALLY: Kannst du mich halten?
>> MURAT: Die drei... Was?
Nein.
Doch.
Warte mal kurz.
Nee, lass. Komm.
>> SALLY: Halte mich hier fest.
>> MURAT: Nee. Ich bin nicht...
>> SALLY: Halte mich fest. Ich springe.
>> MURAT: Nein.
Mach jetzt.
>> SALLY: Halte mich fest.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich halte dich fest.
>> SALLY: Aber lass mich nicht nach hinten fallen.
>> MURAT: Nein, ich lasse dich nicht fallen. Echt nicht.
Oh!
Okay, lass es lieber.
Lass es lieber.
Das funktionieren nur im Fernsehen.
Ihr merkt es auch.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall diese drei Filmsequenzen
muss man kennen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
Und immer, wenn wir zwei so Liebesfilme anschauen,
dann
– und es ist morgens und die stehen morgens auf
und dann knutschen sie immer.
Und ich muss dann...
>> SALLY: Woah, das ist so eklig!
>> MURAT: Ich finde das so eklig, weil das ist dann...
>> SALLY: Uh!
>> MURAT: Dann denke ich mir: "Boah, was geht?!"
>> SALLY: Aber das ist ja nicht nur bei Filmen,
das ist auch bei GZSZ.
>> MURAT: Morgens stehe ich, gucke nach rechts
und denke: "Wer ist das?"
Und andere knutschen sich.
Das ist es dann – das ist der Wahnsinn für mich.
>> SALLY: Hallo, geht Zähne putzen!
>> MURAT: Ja. Okay. Weiter geht's. Genau.
>> SALLY: So. Was jetzt wichtig ist:
>> MURAT: Was?
Nicht da vorne feste drücken,
sondern eher hinten halten
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: und eigentlich ohne Druck arbeiten.
Weil das fließt ja raus.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Jetzt hier einfüllen.
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und nicht zu voll.
>> MURAT: Ich habe es gerade gemerkt.
Hast du es gemerkt? Bei mir hat es blubb gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und nicht zu voll.
Weil, wenn da Luft drin ist...
>> MURAT: Ah, jetzt habe ich es gemerkt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Und es kann sich auch im Hohlkörper Luft bilden.
>> MURAT: Hast du gerade...
Hast du mich gerade gehatet?
>> SALLY: Und dann machst du blubb.
>> MURAT: Hör auf!
Oh, ich habe drübergeschossen.
>> SALLY: O Gott!
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Ich sehe jetzt schon,
Vivi, viel Spaß beim Schneiden.
>> MURAT: Wirklich. Ich glaube, es gibt...
Kann man jetzt so eine erotische Musik drunterlegen
>> MURAT: oder so Liebesmusik,
>> SALLY: O Gott! Hör auf!
>> MURAT: während wir das machen?
>> SALLY: Aber dann musst du mich
auch so erotisch angucken.
[Musik]
Guck, nicht so voll und dann lieber klopfen.
Dann gucken wir, wo es sich setzt,
und füllen es so bis fast unter den Rand.
>> MURAT: Ich wollte gerade sagen,
ein bisschen Liebesmusik machen.
Aber ich muss gerade rülpsen. Ich weiß nicht.
Und dann sind die Pflanzen da.
Es riecht nach Friedhof hier.
Und irgendwoher kommt der Knoblauchgeruch.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich kann mich hier gar nicht so wohlfühlen.
Weißt du das irgendwie?
Bei mir kommt so gar keine Stimmung auf.
Im nächsten Leben
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: heiratest du jemanden, der irgendwie...
>> SALLY: Und du ein Fitness-Model.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau. Ich heirate mal...
>> SALLY: Damit deine Figur in die andere Richtung geht.
>> MURAT: Nächstes Jahr heirate ich...
Was?
So.
In meinem nächsten Leben heirate ich ein Fitness-Model.
Einen Fitness-YouTuber heirate ich.
Er/sie/es/divers.
>> SALLY: Komisch, dass deine Flasche pupst.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So. Jetzt habe ich...
>> SALLY: Jetzt habt ihr Step eins
und Step zwei schon geschafft,
Füllung hergestellt, Pralinen gefüllt.
Und die kommen jetzt kurz ins Tiefkühlfach,
damit die Füllung fest wird
und wir sie gleich verschließen können.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt haben wir Zeit.
Jetzt habt ihr zu Hause eine Stunde Zeit.
>> MURAT: Genau. Jetzt kommen die Fragen.
Ups.
>> SALLY: Jetzt haben sie zu Hause auch eine Stunde Zeit.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich habt daheim jetzt auch eine Stunde Zeit.
[Musik]
Da könnt ihr jetzt Netflix schauen
oder mir bei den Fensterbänken helfen.
So.
Und währenddessen
stelle ich jetzt die Fragen,
die die Zuschauer an mich gestellt haben über meine Frau,
die ich beantworten muss.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt das verstanden,
ihr kleinen Hauptschüler.
>> SALLY: Soll ich die Fragen vorlesen?
>> MURAT: Ja. Warte.
Warte kurz.
Ich lese die Fragen jetzt vor.
Okay.
Also
fangen wir an mit der ersten Frage:
"Was liebt Sally am meisten an dir?"
Das muss ich jetzt beantworten?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und du musst sagen, ob das stimmt.
>> MURAT: Meinen Körper.
Und?
>> SALLY: Deinen Humor.
>> MURAT: Okay.
"Wenn Murat mit einem einen Meter großen Blumenstrauß
kommen würde, was würde Sally sagen?"
Sally würde sagen: "Ich sehe dich nicht mehr."
[Gelächter]
>> SALLY: Deinen Humor.
>> MURAT: Hast du gerade Witze über meine Größe gemacht?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das hätte ich mir gedacht, aber ich hätte gesagt:
"Was hast du heute angestellt?"
>> MURAT: "Warst du ihre große Liebe?"
First Love.
Ja.
Ihre große Liebe
war ich doch?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oder bin ich doch?
>> SALLY: Doch, das bist du.
>> MURAT: Okay.
"Isst Sally auch mal was nicht so Gesundes,
wenn die Kamera aus ist und alle Mitarbeiter weg sind?"
>> MURAT: Ja, voll oft.
Richtig oft.
>> SALLY: Ach so?
>> MURAT: Yammlou.
>> MURAT: Nee, das ist gesund.
>> SALLY: Das ist doch gesund.
>> MURAT: Hä?!
Nächste Frage:
"Streitet ihr auch mal?
Oder ist immer Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen?"
Eigentlich würde das ja passen,
dass bei uns immer Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen ist,
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sein, wir streiten sehr oft.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Wegen ihm.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also wirklich täglich,
eigentlich meistens morgens, mittags, abends
streiten wir.
Aber dann sagt sie...
>> SALLY: Das stimmt doch gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich höre doch meistens weg.
>> MURAT: Ja, so ist es.
Einfach weghören dann.
>> SALLY: Ich höre einfach weg.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und zwar nächste Frage:
"Hat Sally jemals versagt?"
Ja, und zwar am 21. Juli 2008.
Was war da?
>> SALLY: Unsere Hochzeit.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Es gibt manche Fehler,
die begleiten einen das ganze Leben.
Ja. Und es gibt manche Leute, die heiraten ihre Fehler.
Und hier sind sie dann.
"Welche Pflegeserie benutzt Sally so?"
Deine Pflegeserie?
Also so Schminke und so was?
>> SALLY: Wahrscheinlich.
>> MURAT: Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
>> SALLY: Ist auch besser so.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ist aber nicht teuer, gell?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Nee.
Ist okay. Ich habe nichts dagegen.
"Wie lange braucht Sally morgens im Bad?"
Sie braucht zehn Minuten für sich selber
und 15 Minuten dafür, die Sachen wegzuräumen,
die ich dann wieder schmutzig gemacht habe.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
>> MURAT: Ja, zum Beispiel.
"Hat sie schlechte Angewohnheiten,
die sie ablegen möchte?"
Singen. Ja.
Singen würde sie gern ablegen
oder sollte sie normalerweise ablegen.
Ja.
Bei ihrer letzten Karaoke haben wir...
>> SALLY: Habe ich da singen gehört?
Habe ich da
– oh! Sollten wir ein Liebesduett singen heute?
Oh, es wäre Zeit für ein Liebesduett!
Wenn wir heute keines machen,
dann werde ich das Liebesduett
unserer Weihnachtsfeier 2019
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: einblenden.
>> MURAT: Nein, bitte nicht.
>> SALLY: Also sing mit mir heute
>> MURAT: Nein, nein, nein. Nein, mache ich nicht.
>> SALLY: oder wir blenden es ein.
>> MURAT: Schatz, bitte. Sonst verlieren wir alle Leute hier.
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Doch.
>> SALLY: Die sind immer nett, die wollen doch alle Freude.
>> MURAT: Dann kommt dann Frau Merkel
und will dann einen Impfstoff dagegen entwickeln,
sobald du singst.
Ja.
So.
"Kann Sally rückwärts und seitwärts einparken?"
Sally kann rückwärts, seitwärts und von oben einparken.
Glaubt mir das.
Das kann die.
Du denkst zwar, das stimmt jetzt nicht,
>> SALLY: Ich kann besser einparken als er.
>> MURAT: aber einparken kann sie wirklich.
>> SALLY: Kann ich besser als du.
Das musst du schon sagen.
>> MURAT: Ja, nur du hast Probleme mit dem Geradeausfahren.
"Wer würde sich eher impfen lassen?"
Ich glaube, da die Immobilien über mich sind, dann eher
>> SALLY: Stopp!
>> MURAT: ich zuerst.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Über Impfen und Stillen spricht man nicht.
>> MURAT: Ist das Gesetz?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das ist das große Social-Media-Gesetz.
Wenn du eine Diskussion auslösen willst,
dann sag was übers Stillen oder übers Impfen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Machen wir nicht.
>> MURAT: Also ich bin jetzt mal still,
wenn es ums Impfen geht.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: So. Okay.
Aber das war aber richtig Ding
– das war so wie so ein Tagesschau-Moderator.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
Es war gut.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Jetzt hast du mich voll durcheinandergebracht.
Kannst du mal ein paar Fragen über mich?
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte. Warte.
>> MURAT: Ja. So. Was fragen
– ich weiß. Es kommt irgendwas mit den Füßen wieder, gell?
Habe ich recht?
>> SALLY: Also das Erste ist keine Frage, sondern:
"Ich weiß schon zu viel über ihn."
>> MURAT: Über mich?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Wer ist das?
>> SALLY: Lehrer Ralf.
>> MURAT: O Gott, mein Lehrer!
Das ist mein Klassenlehrer.
Das ist der Wahnsinn!
Der Typ verfolgt mich einfach.
Mein Leben lang wird mich der verfolgen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Mein Klassenlehrer, ein ganz cooler Typ.
>> SALLY: Nochmal.papa fragt:
"Hat Murat eigentlich Unterarmimplantate?"
>> MURAT: Ja, das haben mich echt schon voll viele gefragt.
>> SALLY: Hallo? Ich beantworte.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Aber die Frage kommt sehr oft.
>> SALLY: "Was ist Murats Lieblingswort?"
Das hat die Melek gefragt.
Murats Lieblingswort ist: "Genial!"
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn.
>> SALLY: Und Wahnsinn, oder?
>> MURAT: Und so.
>> SALLY: So.
>> MURAT & SALLY: So.
>> MURAT: So.
So.
>> SALLY: "Welches Essen würde Murat niemals anrühren?"
Kürbis,
>> MURAT: Woah!
>> SALLY: Süßkartoffel,
gesund.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Außer ich habe es ungesund verpackt.
>> MURAT: Und dann noch mal in der anderen Reihenfolgen.
Genau.
>> SALLY: "Woran erkennt man, dass Murat hungrig ist?"
Also
da muss man gut beobachten können.
Er wird zur Diva.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Das stimmt wirklich.
>> SALLY: Der Blutzucker sinkt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Er fällt fast vom Stuhl.
Er fängt an, hysterisch Sachen zu suchen.
Und dann isst er ein paar Süßigkeiten.
Und das war es.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Er kann tatsächlich,
wenn er wirklich Hunger hat, kann er
– wir hatten immer früher hier so einen Stand,
"Der Stecher".
>> MURAT: Ja.
O mein Gott! Der heißt wirklich so.
Der macht Schaumküsse.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann haben wir da immer so 25...
>> MURAT: Und dann sagen die Frauen immer:
"Der Stecher war gestern da."
Dabei hat der nur Schaumküsse.
Der heißt wirklich so.
>> SALLY: Und dann haben wir uns immer früher so 25 geholt.
Weißt, so für die ganze Woche.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Dann hast du die...
>> SALLY: Dann erwischt man ihn mit einer Hungerattacke.
>> MURAT: Dann hast du die Schaumküsse da liegen
und dann sagt die: "Ja, boah, cool! Woher hast du die?"
"Vom Stecher."
>> SALLY: "Was liebst du an Sally?"
Was liebt Murat an mir?
>> MURAT: Essen.
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt gedacht, du sagst: "Alles."
>> MURAT: Alles
Essen.
Also alles, egal, was du kochst.
Ja.
>> SALLY: "Was war sein erstes Auto?"
Das weiß ich tatsächlich nicht.
Ich weiß nur, du hattest irgendwann...
>> MURAT: Mein allerallererstes Auto, denk mal nach.
>> SALLY: Du hattest irgendwann so einen BMW Z3.
>> MURAT: Nein, sag das nicht! Sag das nicht!
>> SALLY: War das dein erstes?
>> MURAT: Das ist so was von Klischee.
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Mein aller-
>> SALLY: Doch.
>> MURAT: Das stimmt gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Ach!
>> MURAT: Mein allerallererstes Auto,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen...
>> SALLY: Darf ich sagen, dass du zur Hochzeit
einen 3er BMW gemietet hast?
>> MURAT: Sag doch so was nicht!
Sag mal!
Ich komm mir voll blöd vor.
Die denken jetzt: "Guck mal, der Teppichverkäufer"
und was weiß ich
und Gemüsehändler und was weiß ich was.
Mein erstes Auto, ganz ehrlich, das war
– es war ein Neuwagen.
Das müsst ihr euch echt mal,
mit 18 einen Neuwagen.
Warum?
Weil ich schon ganz, ganz früh
mit Schwarzbaustellen angefangen habe.
Und zwar war das ein Fiat Seicento
und ein gelbes Auto.
>> SALLY: Gelb?
>> MURAT: Wirklich quietschgelb.
>> SALLY: Uh!
>> MURAT: Ohne Witz, alle nannten mich immer Tweety.
>> SALLY: Ach Gott, ey!
>> MURAT: Und jetzt noch muss ich was erzählen.
Es ist voll cool gewesen.
>> SALLY: Okay, erzähl.
>> MURAT: Das aber stimmt jetzt wirklich.
Das war ein Fiat Seicento
und im Radkasten, jetzt ungelogen,
– ich weiß nicht, warum,
ob das normal ist –
da waren Kondome drin.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit denen nicht stimmt.
Aber es stimmt wirklich.
Aber ich weiß es einfach nicht.
Es war einfach – hat mich schockiert.
>> SALLY: Murat!
>> MURAT: Ja, es hat mich schockiert.
Das fand ich furchtbar.
>> SALLY: Ich komme mal zu einer normalen Frage:
"Was ist seine Lieblingsgruppe?"
Lieblingsmusikgruppe.
>> MURAT: Grup Tekkan.
Ja.
Nee, sag. Wer ist meine Lieblingsgruppe?
Jetzt sag mal ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Also zurzeit hörst du gern Clueso.
>> MURAT: Clueso, ja.
>> SALLY: Wie spricht man das aus?
>> SALLY & MURAT: Clueso.
>> SALLY: Du hörst aber auch Coldplay und so.
>> MURAT: Ich mag Coldplay.
Ich mag aber auch sehr, sehr deutsche Musik,
mag ich ganz, ganz arg,
solange sie nicht von Florian Silbereisen ist.
>> SALLY: Wie heißt das eine Lied
von...
>> MURAT: "Adore You" von Harry Styles?
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist ein deutscher Musiker, genau.
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Sportfreunde Stiller.
>> MURAT: Oh, Sportfreunde Stiller ist richtig cool!
>> SALLY: "Kompliment."
>> MURAT: Fanta 4, das ist genau meine Zeit.
Die beste Musik war einfach in den 90ern.
Genau.
Da haben die Jungs noch keine roten Schuhe getragen
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: und keine Hipster-Bärte und was weiß ich,
einfach coole Musik, ein bisschen Gitarre,
dam-dam-dam.
War cool.
>> SALLY: "Wie geht Murat täglich
mit so viel Frauenpower um?"
>> MURAT: Tabletten.
>> SALLY: Wann ist mein Geburtsdatum?
Das würde ich gerne dich direkt fragen.
>> MURAT: 24. August.
>> SALLY: Welches Jahr?
>> MURAT: Sommeranfang.
>> SALLY: Nein, Sommeranfang ist unser Hochzeitstag.
>> MURAT: 2008.
Nee, zweiund-
neunzehnhundertachtundneu-
neunzehnhundert-
Hä?! Bist du 89 oder 88?
89. Du bist 89.
Nicht? 88.
O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: "Was ist sein Lieblingsbuch?"
>> MURAT: Ah, jetzt komm!
>> SALLY: Das mit der Bibliothek.
Das mit dem Mann mit den Büchern.
>> MURAT: Also ich habe vielleicht
– ich habe echt nicht viele Bücher in meinem Leben gelesen.
Also zwei Bilderbücher waren es
und einmal das Telefonbuch.
>> SALLY: Wie heißt das?
>> MURAT: Und das andere, wirklich ein cooles Buch,
das muss ich euch empfehlen.
>> SALLY: Da ist der Anfang,
wo dann der Junge zum dem Bib-
>> MURAT: Genau. Das ist von
>> SALLY: von Louis
>> MURAT & SALLY: Carlos Ruiz Zafón.
>> MURAT: Und zwar "Im Schatten des Windes".
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: Ein Hammerbuch! Lest das wirklich!
Es ist ein Roman.
Normalerweise bin ich kein Romanleser,
normalerweise lese ich nur Sachbücher.
Aber das ist wirklich
ein wundervolles Buch.
Kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, "Im Schatten des Windes".
Das ist keine Produktplatzierung.
Das ist wirklich ein Bestseller übrigens.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Weiter.
>> SALLY: Krass.
"Ist Murat eifersüchtig?"
Nee.
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber du auch nicht.
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: Warum auch?
Ja.
So.
Es war mal...
Die sagt dann immer: "Nimm ihn mit."
Ja.
>> SALLY: Murats Kontostand.
Es pendelt so zwischen 400 und 800 Euro,
weil ich ihm nie zu viel auszahle.
Weil, wenn der Murat mal eine Karte hat,
dann puh, Shopping.
>> MURAT: Ja. Dann hat sie Angst, dass ich abhaue.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Das heißt, nie so viel Geld aufs Konto tun,
dass die Person abhauen könnte.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT: Mit 400 Euro komme ich mit der Bahn
vielleicht gerade mal nach Stuttgart.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ich glaube, die hat die Frage falsch formuliert:
"Was war das Peinlichste,
was dir wegen Sally je geschehen ist?"
Entschuldigung, andersherum!
Was war das Peinlichste,
was mir wegen Murat je geschehen ist?
Jedes Mal, wenn wir einkaufen waren im Supermarkt...
>> SALLY: Das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
>> MURAT: Ich liebe das.
Das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Wir laufen so zusammen
und dann sagt er immer irgendwas Peinliches,
aber so laut,
dass ich jedes Mal im Erdboden versinke.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und ich sage dann immer
– das regt die immer voll auf.
Ich sage immer:
"Entschuldigung, ist das Sally von Sallys Welt?"
>> SALLY: Erstens das
>> MURAT: Und pass auf. Und sie hatte...
>> SALLY: Und zweitens kommt dann
>> SALLY: immer so was Peinliches hinterher:
"Hä? Was machst du jetzt in der Fußpilzabteilung?"
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und das ist so lustig!
Das ist... Genau.
Und wir haben so Codewörter.
Sie mag das nicht, wenn ich sie in der Öffentlichkeit
ganz laut durchs ganze Einkaufszentrum Sally nenne.
Weil was passiert?
Wenn ich sie im Einkaufscenter Sally nenne,
dann sehen das ganz, ganz viele Menschen.
>> SALLY: Wie viele Sallys hat es in Waghäusel?
>> MURAT: Genau. Und dann...
>> SALLY: Und wie viele Murats hat es?
>> MURAT: Deswegen sage ich:
"Sally? Oh, Entschuldigung.
Bist du nicht die Sally Sallys Welt?"
Ja.
Und dann dreht die voll durch.
Ich muss jedes Mal lachen.
Dann ist es immer lustig.
>> SALLY: Ach Gott!
So was bringt der.
>> MURAT: Es ist mir auch langweilig beim Einkaufen.
>> SALLY: Und dann guckt er halt auch immer,
wie ich reagiere,
und vor allem, wie andere reagieren.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ach Gott, ey!
>> MURAT: Und das Coole war mal:
Wir waren mal...
Ich darf jetzt den Namen
– ich darf keine Werbung machen.
Wir waren im Discounter.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und dann...
Dann habe ich
– Ela habe ich Esmeralda genannt.
>> SALLY: Stimmt!
>> MURAT: Genau. Dann habe ich Ela Esmeralda genannt.
Und dann hat die
– was hat die an der Kasse gesagt?
>> SALLY: Die hat gesagt...
>> MURAT: "Ihr braucht gar nicht so tun.
Ich weiß, wer ihr seid."
Das war so cool!
"Das ist nicht Esmeralda. Das ist Ela."
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Und die Ela: "Hä? Ich bin nicht Esmeralda."
Ja.
>> SALLY: O Mannomann!
"Bekommt Murat über Instagram
Nacktfotos von Frauen, Männern, diversen?"
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Seit Kurzem.
Doch.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Per Nachricht?
>> MURAT: Ich habe es nie gezeigt.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Zeig es mir auch nicht.
>> MURAT: Aber das sind
– ich muss sagen, das sind so Spam-Seiten.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ja, ich kenne die Spam-Seiten.
>> MURAT: Hast du die auch?
Das kriegst du doch auch, oder?
>> SALLY: Aber bei mir schreiben immer nur Frauen.
>> MURAT: Bei mir auch.
>> SALLY: Mh.
Okay.
>> MURAT: Das ist jetzt kein Aufruf,
dass mir auch Männer schreiben sollen,
aber es ist...
Aber es sind diese Spam-Seiten.
Also ich bekomme keine irgendwie.
Ich finde immer, das stimmt oftmals nicht,
was man immer so hört.
Ich meine irgendwie so das Darknet
und was weiß ich was und mit allem Drum und Dran
und nur schlimme Sachen.
Also ich bekomme eigentlich keine.
Wieso bekomme ich keine
Nacktbilder von anderen Menschen?
>> SALLY: Sag es nicht.
>> MURAT: Das kann ja Gründe haben.
Bin ich es nicht wert?
>> SALLY: Ach Gott, ey!
>> MURAT: Macht es ja nicht! Macht es ja nicht!
Bitte! Ich schwöre, ich müsste voll lachen.
Bitte macht das nicht.
>> SALLY: Da muss ich jetzt tatsächlich überlegen:
"Wer ist deine Lieblingsschauspielerin?"
Ich glaube, du magst Demi Moore.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Jodie Fox?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Wer ist das?
>> SALLY: Die Blonde.
>> MURAT: Nee.
Soll ich es dir sagen?
>> SALLY: Jennifer Aniston?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Jessica Alba?
>> SALLY: Jetzt habe ich dir so viele schöne Frauen genannt.
>> MURAT: Charlize Theron.
>> SALLY: Wie sieht die aus?
>> MURAT: Gut.
>> SALLY: Zeig.
>> MURAT: Guck dir jetzt...
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Guck dir den Film "Monster" an.
>> MURAT: Schaut euch den Film "Monster" an.
Ein cooler Film übrigens.
Ehrlich, cool. Also es ist kein Liebesfilm,
aber es ist ein richtig cooler Film.
"Monster" mit Charlize Theron.
>> SALLY: So. Und jetzt die
>> MURAT: Das ist eine Australierin.
>> SALLY: letzte Frage:
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: "Ist Sally deine Traumfrau?"
>> MURAT: Hä? Das musst doch du beantworten.
>> SALLY: Ach so. Ja.
>> MURAT: Gut.
Ist das auch geklärt.
>> SALLY: So.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay.
Dann sind wir durch mit der Fragerunde.
Dann geht es weiter mit unseren
>> SALLY: Pralinen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
Rudi, was ist?
Können wir die Pralinen drin lassen?
Weil ich habe gerade ein Steak entdeckt.
>> SALLY: Ah!
Nein! Das mache ich später.
So. Weiter geht es.
Warte, warte.
Nimm das für die ergonomische Höhe.
>> MURAT: Hast du mich gerade gehatet?
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Wegen meiner Größe?
>> SALLY: Ich will mich nur nicht so arg runterbücken.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also es kann passieren,
dass die Kugel mal oben klebt.
Aber das macht nichts.
Nehmt sie einfach runter.
Nicht naschen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
Ja, die sind jetzt schön gefroren, wie ihr sehen könnt.
Und jetzt nehme ich einfach
noch ein bisschen Kuvertüre zum Verschließen.
Die kommt jetzt hier einfach in so eine Schmelzschale.
Das Wasser habe ich bereits kochen lassen,
habe es vom Herd wieder runtergenommen.
Und jetzt einfach warm schmelzen.
Jetzt habt ihr wieder ein bisschen Zeit.
>> MURAT: Das könnt ihr auch über einem Topf machen.
>> SALLY: Ja, über einem Topf geht auch.
>> MURAT: Über einem normalen Topf.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder auch in der Mikrowelle.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Geht auch.
So.
Wenn ihr das dann habt,
könnt ihr jetzt entweder mit einem Löffel
zum Beispiel die Schokolade da draufgeben
und verschließen
oder ihr nehmt einen kleinen Spritzbeutel
oder eine Gefriertüte geht auch.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Also ihr müsst das ganze Werkzeug...
Seid ein bisschen kreativ.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Komm, wir machen Partner Work.
Du bist der Spritzbeutelständer.
>> MURAT: Das ist ja ein Minispritzbeutel.
>> SALLY: Ja, Habibis.
>> MURAT: Habibis.
Die nennen sich Habibi-Spritzbeutel.
Voll süß!
>> SALLY: So.
Die Schokolade sollte jetzt auch nicht so heiß sein.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Du hättest es auch in deiner Hand
wieder schmelzen können, nicht?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Du heißer Typ.
Da wäre aber der ganze Beutel geschmolzen,
nicht nur die Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Magst du das machen?
>> MURAT: Ja, das würde ich jetzt auch mal gern machen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Warte. Ich hole kurz einen Verschluss.
>> MURAT: Weil ich kenne mich gut aus mit Spritzbeuteln.
>> SALLY: O Gott!
>> MURAT: Weil ich habe ihn...
Ich habe über 800 Quadratmeter
oder laufende Meter, wie auch immer,
Fugenmörtel gespritzt mit einem Spritzbeutel.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Ich verschließe es dann einfach
so mit so einer Klammer.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Vor allem für Ungeübte ganz gut, weil
– also ich drehe es ja hinten zu und nehme es so.
Aber für den Murat würde ich das jetzt so machen.
Jetzt vorne eine kleine Spitze abschneiden.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt ist aber wichtig, dass du
– hier, guck mal.
Es ist nämlich
– darf ich es dir einfach zeigen?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es ist nämlich nicht wichtig, dass es gut aussieht,
sondern einfach, dass es so richtig verschlossen ist,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: damit später diese...
>> MURAT: Ah ja.
Guckt mal. Das mit dem Spritzbeutel
würde ich euch empfehlen.
>> SALLY: Das geht, nicht?
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
So.
Ich mache das schon.
>> SALLY: Damit der Joghurt dann nicht rauskommt, weißt?
>> MURAT: Kann das sein...
Guck mal. Boah!
>> SALLY: Also der Frischkäse.
>> MURAT: Guck mal, wie das aussieht.
Hey, das macht sogar Spaß hier so.
Und dann geht es auch richtig schnell.
Also, wenn du...
>> SALLY: Pst!
Sendepause.
Halt!
Murat, du musst ruhig...
Guck mal. Du musst es richtig zumachen.
>> MURAT: Weißt du was? Mach du es.
>> JOSH: Gibt es jetzt Ehestreit?
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Nein, es gibt keinen Ehestreit,
wenn er die Dinger jetzt richtig verschließt.
>> MURAT: Also, wenn du perfekte Fotos haben willst,
dann mach es selber.
>> SALLY: Jetzt mach es so, wie ich es dir gesagt habe.
Es muss einfach zu sein, damit die Füllung nicht rauskommt.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Ihr könnt den Pralinenkurs
auch mit eurer Freundin machen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So. Hier, du kleiner Monk.
Mach es selber. Da.
>> SALLY: Nein, nein, nein.
>> MURAT: Doch, mach es selber.
>> SALLY: Magst du solang abspülen?
>> MURAT: Ja ich spüle ab. Komm.
>> SALLY & MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: So umgeht ihr einen Ehestreit.
>> MURAT: So.
Egal, wie ich es jetzt machen würde,
es würde ihr nie genügen.
>> MURAT & SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das stimmt doch gar nicht!
Komm. Probier es noch mal.
>> MURAT: Nein, ich will es gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Doch! Komm.
>> MURAT: Ich habe gar keine Lust drauf,
weil mir das alles viel zu eine filigrane Arbeit ist,
muss ich ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ich bin eher der Typ,
der das 400-Gramm-Tomahawk-Steak wendet,
und fertig.
Das geht mir auch viel zu langsam,
wie du das machst.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weißt du eigentlich, wie lange ich hier
normalerweise Videos...
>> MURAT: Okay, war ein Spaß. Mach es nicht so schnell.
Es soll doch auch schön aussehen.
>> SALLY: Aha! Will jetzt doch einer noch perfekte Bilder?
>> MURAT: Oh, das war jetzt gerade cool.
Wow! Was ist denn das für ein Move?
>> SALLY: Der hier?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gefällt der dir?
>> MURAT: Ja, der gefällt mir.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Wenn sie dann verschlossen sind,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: kommen sie noch mal in den Gefrierschrank
oder Kühlschrank, damit die Schokolade fest wird.
Die Schokolade hier wird temperiert.
Das heißt, zuerst mal zwei Drittel auf dem Herd erwärmen,
also im Wasserbad schmelzen lassen, runternehmen
und dann das restliche Drittel dazu,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: damit sie keinen Grauschleier bekommt.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Außer ihr nehmt sehr, sehr hochwertige Schokolade.
Dann...
>> SALLY: Da ist es wirklich einfacher sogar.
Da habt ihr nicht so schnell den Grauschleier.
>> SALLY: Guck mal.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Unsere leckere Schokolade
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: sieht wundervoll aus,
schön glänzend, dickflüssig.
>> MURAT: Kann ich die Blumen wegstellen?
>> SALLY: Boah, die riechen echt ein bisschen. Ja.
>> MURAT: Wirklich. Das ist echt...
Das ist der Grund, warum ich dir keine Blumen schenke.
>> SALLY: Dann schenk mir doch gut riechende Blumen.
Dann jetzt gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY & MURAT: und Kokosnuss.
>> SALLY: Und die jetzt zerkleinern.
>> MURAT: Genau. Bei denen müsst ihr aufpassen,
weil die sind richtig teuer.
>> SALLY: Ja. Die gibt es aber auch
in der Babynahrungsabteilung in kleinen Päckchen.
>> MURAT: Genau. Die sind halt so teuer,
weil man halt vielleicht...
Wenn du sie gefriertrocknest,
kriegst du vielleicht aus einem Kilogramm Himbeeren
vielleicht gerade mal
100 Gramm zusammen.
>> SALLY: Maximum. Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Deswegen sind sie so teuer.
>> SALLY: Ja, weil eben das Wasser entzogen ist.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: So. Das geben wir kurz in den Mixer.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Eins,
zwei,
drei,
los.
>> SALLY: Das ist so süß, wie du immer zählst!
[Musik]
Okay, stopp. Reicht.
>> MURAT: Twenty Sense of...
>> SALLY: Fifty Shades.
>> MURAT: Ah, Fifty Shades of Grey.
>> SALLY: Ist dir das Liebesrot gut?
Gefällt dir die Farbe?
>> MURAT: Mmh! Das riecht voll nach Ding,
nach Erdbeere und Kokos
– Himbeer und Kokos.
Was ist das?
>> SALLY: Himbeer und Kokos.
>> MURAT: Hm. Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Möchtest du kurz die Pralinen holen?
>> MURAT: Ja. Welche?
Ah, okay.
>> SALLY: So. Wir machen jetzt Partnerarbeit.
Willst du eher das Schmuddelige machen
oder eher das Saubere?
>> MURAT: Ich mag das Schmuddelige voll.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Das habe ich mir gedacht.
>> SALLY: Weil ich mache mir die Hände nicht schmutzig.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das ist jetzt wirklich Partnerarbeit.
Also Pralinen sind wirklich Partner Work.
Warum fehlt da eine?
>> MURAT: Wir haben eine Ratte.
>> SALLY: Eine Muratte.
>> MURAT: Ja, eine Muratte.
Eine ist weg. Ich weiß nicht, wo die ist.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Einfach ein bisschen Schokolade in die Hand.
>> MURAT: Das wird jetzt schon,
also das ist schon erotisch jetzt.
Also das ist mir schon zu viel. Also...
>> SALLY: Jetzt den Partner damit einreiben.
>> MURAT: Ab jetzt abschalten, Mama, bitte.
Wenn meine Mutter jetzt zuschaut...
>> SALLY: Jetzt die Kugel nehmen, drin rollen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und du hast jetzt saubere Hände
und deswegen nimmst du jetzt den Teller
und schüttelst den so,
damit die sich komplett damit ummantelt.
>> MURAT: Spätestens jetzt solltet ihr vielleicht abschalten,
weil es vielleicht nicht mehr jugendfrei wird. Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt wird es schmutzig.
>> MURAT: Vielleicht ist euch auch aufgefallen,
dass hier gerade keine Werbung
in dem ganzen Video eingeblendet wurde,
weil alle gesagt haben: Nee.
>> MURAT: Guck mal, wie krümelig das war.
>> SALLY: Amorelie?
>> MURAT: Wie kriege ich es – ich weiß...
>> SALLY: Du musst es aber ein bisschen schneller machen,
damit es wirklich komplett ummantelt.
>> MURAT: Wie die Chinesen?
>> SALLY: Nee, so wie du. Du bist ja auch manchmal schnell.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
>> MURAT: Darf ich dir nachher die Hände sauber machen?
Auf jeden Fall,
in diesem Moment merkt ihr,
warum man Pralinen mit dem Partner machen sollte.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Hallo?
>> MURAT: Ach so. Entschuldigung.
>> SALLY: Schüttel, schüttel, schüttel!
Schüttel dein Ding!
Schüttel deinen Speck! Schüttel, schüttel deinen Speck!
>> MURAT: So.
Ich finde das voll cool. Jetzt weiter?
>> SALLY: Und jetzt nimmst du sie raus auf den Teller,
auf den sauberen.
>> MURAT: Ah, pass auf.
Ich tu sie so ein bisschen rollen, okay?
>> SALLY: Ja, die musst du halt rollen,
wenn sie noch nass sind.
>> MURAT: Ich rolle sie doch schon. Guck mal.
>> SALLY: Jetzt nimm sie raus,
dass ich wieder weiterschmeißen kann.
>> MURAT: So.
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> SALLY: Das sind mal Liebeskugeln!
Schüttel, schüttel, schüttel!
>> MURAT: Ach, das sind Liebeskugeln?
O mein Gott!
Hier kommen Begriffe! Ich mache mich voll fertig!
Ich habe voll Angst,
dass jetzt die Kinder daheim irgendwas googeln.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Kinder dürfen noch nicht allein an Google.
Also meine Kinder nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja. Also jetzt...
>> SALLY: Weiter, weiter, weiter! Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Komm!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich sind wir ja fertig, nicht?
Wir rollen das noch alleine fertig.
Los.
>> MURAT: Eine halbe Stunde später.
Oder bei manchen
>> SALLY: Das habe ich doch gar nicht gemeint.
>> MURAT: zwei Minuten später.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gedacht, wir haben genug Aufnahmen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Murat summt]
>> SALLY: My darling!
Jetzt wird es ja richtig romantisch.
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Jetzt bist du auch schmutzig.
>> MURAT: Hast du meine Haare jetzt gerade Ding gemacht?
Wie nennt sich das?
Sugaring.
>> SALLY: Darf ich?
>> MURAT: Nein. Mach das bitte nicht.
Ach Schatz! Da hast du mich echt voll eingesaut.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung.
>> MURAT: Hör doch auf!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Okay.
Wir probieren gleich.
>> MURAT: Hast du einen leichten Wahnsinn? Kann das sein?
Ich habe gerade das in deinen Augen gesehen.
>> SALLY: Wir probieren jetzt gleich unsere Kugeln.
>> MURAT: Psycho.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Oh, she's sweet but a psycho!
Wenn ihr bis zu diesem Punkt ankommt
und wirklich die Praline so, wie sie jetzt aussieht, schafft,
>> MURAT: dann ist es wahre Liebe.
>> SALLY: dann ist es wahre Liebe.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Liebt euch.
O mein Gott!
So.
Auf jeden Fall, es war richtig schön mit der...
Ich muss gleich auf die Baustelle.
Ich muss jetzt
– die Romantik breche ich jetzt hier ab.
Es war toll, hat Spaß gemacht mit meiner Frau.
>> SALLY: Echt? War es das jetzt?
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
Ich weiß...
Egal, was ich sage,
ich assoziiere immer irgendwas Komisches damit.
Auf jeden Fall ging das schnell jetzt.
Es ist ein schnelles Rezept gewesen.
>> SALLY: Wie immer.
>> MURAT: Und macht das auf jeden Fall nach.
>> SALLY: Wollen wir probieren?
>> MURAT: Ach so.
Ich habe ja...
>> SALLY: Halt! Abbeißpflicht.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY & MURAT: Hm.
Das Tonkabohne ist richtig
aphrodisierend.
Echt.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht gehst du jetzt doch nicht zur Baustelle,
sondern bleibst hier.
Aber
jetzt mal mit Ernst
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: bei der Sache.
Das ist eine richtig coole Pralinenfüllung.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weil normalerweise sind die ja immer so cremig
und schwer, aber davon kann man echt mehr essen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ich könnt
– anstelle auch von Kokos könnt ihr auch Haselnüsse nehmen,
finde ich jetzt. Das hätte ich jetzt cooler gefunden.
>> SALLY: Oder auch weglassen.
>> MURAT: Weil ich mag nicht diese Kokosflocken,
weil die hängen dann überall in den Zähnen rum.
>> SALLY: Echt? Hast du so große Zahnlücken?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und auf jeden Fall, ich würde dann Ding nehmen.
Und habt viel Spaß.
Unterstützt die Blumenhändler.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
In eurem Ort.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir daraus so ein Valentinstagsset machen?
>> MURAT: Genau, wir machen ein Valentinstagsset daraus,
dass ihr zu Hause
Fifty Shades of Grey,
Titanic und was weiß ich, alles laufen lassen könnt.
>> SALLY: Ihr könnt es aber auch mit eurer besten Freundin
einfach machen, so einen Mädelsnachmittag, Mädelsabend,
so: All the single ladies,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: alle so kein Valentinstagsdate.
>> MURAT: Oder mit den Kindern.
>> SALLY: So: Put your hands up!
>> MURAT: Und wenn ihr jemanden nicht leiden könnt,
dann macht ihr das, was ich dem Güni mache nachher,
ein Stück Senf rein. Richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Schmeckt bestimmt auch.
>> MURAT: Genau. Oder Butter, einfach nur Butter.
Wirklich, das ist doch voll eklig.
Stell dir vor, nur Butter im Mund.
>> SALLY: Oh! Das ist echt eklig!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Genau. Das könnt ihr auch machen, so Fake-Pralinen.
Wäre cool.
>> SALLY: Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Habt einen schönen Valentinstag.
Das wollte ich für das Bild aufheben, aber egal.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Habt einen schönen Valentinstag.
Und das Rezept findet ihr natürlich in meiner App.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Du warst ein super Partner.
>> MURAT: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß, mit dir gehen wir durch dick und dünn.
>> MURAT: Hm.
War das eine Anspielung auf mich?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gesagt, wir gehen durch dick und dünn.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, wir sind dick und dünn.
>> MURAT: Ich kann mich bei meiner Mutter nur entschuldigen.
Es tut mir leid für die vielen zweideutigen
Wörter und Redewendungen in dem ganzen Video.
Mach's gut, Mama.
>> SALLY: O Gott!
>> MURAT: Ich liebe dich.
Passt auf euch auf. Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Du hast öffentlich mehr Liebeserklärungen
an deine Mutter gemacht als an mich.
>> MURAT: Ja. Ich liebe meine Mutter.
>> SALLY: Ich auch. >> MURAT: Tschüss, Mama.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gedacht, wir gehen zusammen.
>> MURAT: Nein.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: ASMR-Aufnahme läuft.
Ernsthaft?
Wir machen gerade eine ASMR-Aufnahme.
Komm, schließ einfach die Tür ab.
Hallo!
Ach du meine Güte!
Komm, wir probieren es noch einmal.
Nichts kriegen wir hier gebacken ASMR.
[Musik]
Woran merkt man,
dass Murat Hunger hat?
>> MURAT: Ich liebe diese...
>> SALLY: Er geht einfach an den Backschrank
und plündert ihn.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Sehr schön macht ihr das.
Ein bisschen mehr Drama.
Ein bisschen mehr Liebe.
Ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen – okay, ich starte...
>> MURAT: Tu dich mal an mich anlehnen.
>> SALLY: Da muss ich aber so weit runter.
>> SARAH: Gut. Ich habe es.
>> SALLY: Lehn du dich an mir an.
>> MURAT: Hm. Okay.
>> SARAH: Ja, lehn du dich an ihr an.
Gut.